[Musique]
bonsoir diagonal l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
bonsoir bonsoir Stéphane dans une
émission exceptionnellement différée ce
soir oui tout à fait pour des raisons
techniques nous n'enregistrons pas en
direct ce soir donc nous serons un petit
peu en retard sur l'actualité de sarievo
mais évidemment cela est rattrapé
puisqu'il y a des flash spéciales tous
les matins sur diagonale à 9h30
rediffusé toute la journée voilà le
flash spéciau tous les matins jusqu'à la
fin du tournoi euh alors tournoi de
sarevo un tournoi qui a beaucoup
d'histoire d'abord première chose
tournoi qui a démarré en 1957 oui en
fait là nous passons à notre première
rubrique donc qui est l'événement de la
[Musique]
semaine voilà donc l'événement de la
semaine évidemment c'est ce tournois de
sarayavo donc comme je disais qui a
démarré en 1957 donc euh bientôt enfin
plus de 40 ans d'âge c'est donc un
tournoi qui a une grande histoire oui
grande histoire c'est la marque de tous
les grands tournois tout le monde se
rappelle du tournoi d'astings dont les
premières éditions étaient dans les
années 1920 ça fait partie des
traditions et à sarayevo donc ville des
échecs puisque tous les Bosniaques sont
très très fan du noble jeu et bien ça a
commencé en 1957 donc un tournoi
évidemment très très vieux également
alors avec toute une série d'événement
qui ont marqué ce tournoi notamment on
peut noter la victoire de Victor kchnoy
en 1969 et la victoire de Victor kchno
en 1998 donc à 30 ans de différence
kchno gagne le tournoi oui donc là
effectivement c'est c'est c'est une
remarque sur Victor kchno sur ce grand
personnage des échecs qui depuis 30 ans
est sur le haut de laffiche et donc dès
1969 il gagnait ce tourno de sievo quand
c'était encore un Open et même quand
c'était un tournoi fermé très fort de
catégorie 15 en 1998 il le gagnait
encore donc victor kchnoy est un très
grand des échecs effectivement tu
parlais de catégorie de catégorie 15 en
98 la catégorie de ce tournoi n'a cessé
d'augmenter depuis 1978 8 il était en
catégorie 6 à l'époque avec 2368 points
de moyen ho il est aujourd'hui une en
catégorie 19 avec plus de 2700 points ho
ce qui en fait un des plus grands
tournois du monde oui c'est un des
quatre tournois de l'année avec Linares
vaikonzi et en autre qui qui dépend en
fonction des années qui dépend du niveau
des joueurs mais ça fait partie d'un des
tournois donc du grand schlem des échecs
on peut appeler ça comme ça catégorie
donc 19 2701 moyenne lot c'est une
performance pour cette édition 2000 du
tournoi Bosna sarevo alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire d'autre sur ce tournoi
c'est évidemment c'est la liste des
joueurs alors quels sont les joueurs
participants on a une liste de joueurs
tout à fait remarquable avec d'abord
d'abord le numéro 1 mondial est reconnu
et reconnu depuis plus de 15 ans il
s'agit de Gary Kasparov donc chaque fois
qu'il participe un tournoi c'est un
événement il a déjà joué cette année à
viikandzi il a gagné le tournoi il a
joué à Linares il a gagné le tournoi il
joue ici à sarievo il est encore bien
entendu gros favori de ce tournoi gros
favori il est avec d'autres joueurs du
top 5 mondial avec Alexey Shirov et
Alexander morozevic qui est qui est
aussi tout près du top 5 on retrouve
aussi Michael Adams donc on retrouve nos
deux vainqueurs des deux tournois Grand
Prix du Siena et Grand Prix de Bordeaux
dans ce dans ce tournoi sarevo oui deux
valeurs sûr des échecs mondio Michael
Adams le numéro 1 anglais connu depuis
très longtemps sa progression est
constante depuis qu'il joue aux échecs
là il arrive dans les places d'honneur
dans les meilleures places et il est
aujourd'hui donc capable de remporter un
tournoi comme Sarajevo c'est donc c'est
très bien Alex Shirov également lui
alors lui par contre est encore une
montée en puissance encore plus grande
puisque il a battu Vladimir kramnick en
match c'est un joueur de match il est
très très fort quand c'est un combat un
contre un maintenant en tournoi il a
encore à faire ses preuves ici il a une
occasion supplémentaireasion
supplémentaire on retrouve Nigel short
l'anglais qui aussi revient un petit peu
dans les tournois du top niveau disons
que Nigel short n'a pas joué depuis très
longtemps un fort tournoi là c'est une
occasion pour lui de revenir de revenir
sur le haut de la scène mais
effectivement une performance est
attendue puisque que il ne fait plus
partie il est un peu sorti du cercle des
meilleurs mondiaux et là il fait office
d'outsider dans ce tournoi alors le
local de l'épreuve aussi Ivan Sokolov
alors c'est ça c'est un joueur bosniaac
qui donc fait office de Wild Card dans
le tournoi oui les tournois en Bosnie il
y a toujours des joueurs serbe croate et
bosniaque bien
entendu bon Yvan Sokolov c'est le
meilleur joueur yoslave c'est clair avec
Pedrag Nikolic c'est les deux plus forts
ici ils ont choisi V Sokolov parce que
c'est un fan de sarevo il est bosniiaac
il est complètement
bosniaac bon il va avoir du mal c'est un
tournoi difficile pour lui mais il a une
certaine expérience du top niveau ici
l'an dernier je crois le seul joueur qui
a battu Kasparov c'est le seul joueur à
avoir battu Kasparov l'année dernière je
crois que c'était au tournoi de veikonzi
il avait remporté une très belle
victoire avec les pièces blanches donc
il est capable de battre n'importe qui
mais par contre son jeu a encore à mûir
dans certaines positions classiques et
tranquille il joue des ouvertures un peu
étranges un peu alternatives qu'il
connaît bien mais il n'a pas un style
très classique et ça ça peut lui poser
des problèmes dans ce genre de tournoi
alors aussi on retrouve evgie barev
Veline Topalov Michel rugurevic Kiril
gorgev et Sergey mesian tout un panel de
joueurs très fort un panel de joueurs
très fort on peut détailler un petit peu
mil gorevic est l'ancien entraîneur de
Kasparov il habite actuellement en
Belgique et il a fait un bon dans le
classement hlo gigantesque c'està-dire
qu'il a été propulsé dans le cercle trè
TR étroit des plus de 2007 plus de 2700
points ho mil gorevic c'est c'est la
surprise constante il est capable du
meilleur comme du pire notamment la
première partie qu'il a joué dans ce
tournoi où il a perdu une pièce en 11
coups contre morozevic doncèce il a
donné une pièce enfin il l'a donné il
l'a perdu on ne sait pas trop ce qui
s'est passé mais par contre il est
capable de remporter des Open il a un
palmarès très très étoffé très très
élogieux c'était le trème joueur mondial
dans les années 90 derrière carpov et
Kasparov alors il y a également Sergey
movsessian le joueur arménien maintenant
converti en
tchéchoslovaque qui lui donc est jeune
c'est sa première expérience dans un
tournoi très très fort ça va être très
très délicat qui avait réussi à être
quartdefinaliste je crois au championnat
du monde c'était une des surprises de
Las Vegas Las Vegas 99 du championn du
monde FIDÉ il avait très très bien joué
donc c'est probablement un très bon
joueur de match il doit avoir les Neres
solides ça ça peut l'aider
malheureusement son niveau de jeu n'est
en principe pas à la hauteur pour ce
genre de tournoi mais bien entendu des
ner plus du talent plus un jeune un
joueur jeune ça peut ça peut tout
changer evgie barf aussiie barev lui
alors est plus âgé il est un peu sorti
sorti de ce cercle de de très fort
joueurs euh bon c'est un il a la
formation russe donc il il joue très
classique très très fort très très bien
il est très bien préparé dans les
ouvertures mais il lui manque le génie
le le génie le petit coup de peps qui
lui permet de enfin qui lui permettrait
en tout cas d'accéder aux CIN meilleures
places mondiales yevgenie barev une
valeur sûre mais toujours à la recherche
d'un exploit alors un qui dont on admet
qu'il a souvent du génie c'est veseline
Topalov qui est présent aussi Topalov
qui avait fait un très bon tourno de
Monaco veslin Topalov alors lui c'est
effectivement c'est c'est le feu sur les
chiquers il joue toutes ses parties pour
le gain veslin Topalov a expliqué un
jour qu'il préférait faire 2/ 11 dans un
tournoi que 5 sur 11 du moment qu'il
avait gagné deux parties au lieu de
faire 10 nuls pour lui ce qui compte aux
échecs ce n'est pas la défaite ou l'an
nulle c'est juste la victoire ce qui
explique qu'il joue toutes ses parties à
fond pour le gain et donc c'est un
élément très très très très intéressant
très très important c'est lui qui va
faire du spectacle c'est lui qui va
chercher à mettre le feu et Veline
Topalov est imprévisible il est capable
du meilleur comme du pire gorgief en
fait donc c'est le le Bulgare euh Kiril
gorgief est bulgare euh lui alors c'est
surprenant puisqu'il n'est ni jeune ni
spécialement talentueux ni euh ni très
médiatique c'est un élément surprise
dans ce tournoi c'est un élément
totalement surprise il a un fond de jeu
très fort c'est clair Korf joue très
très bien euh maintenant bon ça marche
il remporte beaucoup de victoires en
Open il il est très fort contre les
joueurs 2500 2600 c'est-à-dire contre
les joueurs les forts grand maîtres il a
un score écrasant et il est vraiment
extrêmement fort dans ces contre ces
joueurs là alors maintenant on va voir
ce que ça va donner dans dans un tournoi
comme sarev alors et enfin donc la la
surprise pour nous Français de ce
tournoi c'est l'invitation d'Étienne
bacra la star nationale oui le meilleur
pour la fin notre ami Étienne Étienne
donc qui est déjà passé plusieurs fois
dans diagonal on se rappelle de son
match contre Judit polgard qui l'avait
gagné ou qu'on avait retransmis en
direct qu'on avait retransmis en direct
à Bastien et qui est donc disponible en
différé dans dans dans diagonal si vous
cherchez dans le passé des émissions
vous pourrez revivre ce match bakro
poulgare il a récemment fait nul contre
anatolly carpov 3-3 au Festival des Jeux
cette année à Cann donc ktienne bakro
est en pleine forme est en superbe forme
et il arrive ici à sarevo déterminé en
tout cas tout le monde l'attend dans
cette compétition c'est la star
française c'est la star hexagonale le
chouchou diagonal pour ainsi dire en
tout cas pour ce tournoi ça va être très
dur bon maistien a beaucoup progresser
alors c'est vraiment l'inconnu de ce
tournoi il est très solide il est très
fort maintenant ici de toute façon que
son résultat soit bon ou mauvais ça sera
sa première expérience ça sera une
expérience qui lui permettra d'aller
plus loin qui permettra d'aller plus
loin mais faut espérer quand même qu'il
va pas être le comment on dit le le
pching ball du tournoi parce que c'est
c'est aussi le risque hein c'est quand
même le plus le moins fort le moins fort
de tous les joueurs c'est clairement le
moins expérimenté ça c'est sûr puisqu'il
est très jeune c'est c'est le plus jeune
joueur du tournoi euh bon il va falloir
qu'il ait l'éner solide parce
qu'effectivement si on commence par
perdre plusieurs parties de suite
ensuite on a beaucoup de mal puisque
tout le monde commence à s'acharner
contre le le joueur le dernier joueur du
tournoi ce qui est normal donc en
arrivant déjà il fait office un peu de
de punching ball c'est le cas de le dire
tous les joueurs vont jouer à fond
contre lui euh ses résultats des
premières rondes ne l'ont pas arrangé
malheureusement puisqu'il a perdu la
première contre Gary Kasparov enfin on
va revenir sur cette séquence résultat
mais en tout cas effectivement ça serait
bien qu'Étienne fasse quelques nuls
arrive à calmer le jeu arrive un peu à
prendre la mesure de ce genre de tournoi
et dans ce cas-là il serait capable
effectivement de remporter des très
belles victoires et de gagner des
parties donc on peut peut-être par
parler des résultats justement de d'hier
puisqu'on est donc aujourd'hui jeudi
mission éant différé donc les résultats
donc K gorgf a battu Sergey mosvessian
dans une très belle partie avec avec des
fous une paire de fous contre un fou et
cavalier oui oui oui donc une belle
belle réalisation technique de Kiril
gorgief qui bat Sergey msessian donc
dans cette première ronde quoi dire
c'est un bon départ pour gorgief
effectivement msession qui fait
également partie des gros ider des des
points qu'on a envie de marquer dans ce
tournoi c'estàdire qu' est la cible de
tous ces de tous ces requins qui sont
habitués de ces tournois début difficile
et donc il va falloir qu'il calme le jeu
donc final Kasparov bakro 1-0 aussi
alors là ça c'était donc ça donc c'est
le c'est le mauvais c'est la mauvaise
surprise à la fois au tirage au sort que
Étienne tombe contre Kasparov prier la
première ronde et c'est la mauvaise
surprise au résultat évidemment c'est la
mauvaise surprise à la couleur puisqu'il
avait les Noirs c'est la mauvaise
surprise parce que c'est la première
ronde et donc Etienne a pas le temps
d'entrer dans le n'a pas le temps de se
chauffer pour cette rencontre que tout
le monde attendait c'était quand même la
la grosse affiche en tout cas pour les
joueurs français bakro Kasparov c'est
arrivé un petit peu vite Étienne était
pas encore très chaud il a joué un peu
petit bras mais comme c'est la partie de
la semaine on y reviendra on y reviendra
forcément ensuite morzevic bah gorevic
alors gorevic qui au 11e coup donne une
pièce oui alors ça c'était la partie la
partie incroyable d'hier enfin de de
cette première journée du du championnat
de Sarajevo morozevic donc joue une
ouverture totalement classique un peu un
peu surprenante puisqu'il a laissé son
roi au centre et il commence à attaquer
gourevic côté donc côté droit vers l'roi
de gourevic et là tout de suite il joue
G5 attaquant le cavalier F6 et gourevic
incroyable joue cavalier pr pion E4
alors que ça perd une pièce alors qu'il
aurait pu jouer cavalier8 et essayer de
se défendre il préfère donner une pièce
donc c'est je ne sais pas ce qui est
passé par la tête de gorevic à ce
moment-là en tout cas il a perdu cette
partie pour ainsi dire sans jouer
puisque il n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
de revenir dans cette partie donc
c'était la grosse surprise d' et là je
vous invite à voir le flash de diagonale
de jeudi
matin puisque puisqu'on a commenté un
peu la partie vous aurez donc la partie
en détails toujours dans les différentes
diagonales oui et enfin donc pour les
victoires on va parler nul après topalof
avec les Noirs B short donc très bon
résultat toalov tu disais c'est un
joueur qui joue pour le gain il démarre
très fort le tournoi parce que gagner sa
première partie avec les Noirs c'est
presque lui qui fait le meilleur départ
clairement clairement contre n short qui
est un joueur confirmé un joueur très
très fort veseline Topalov s'impose avec
les Noirs c'est pas facile c'est très
difficile et ici donc très bon départ
pour Veline Topalov il va être en
confiance et il est capable dans
certaines parties de déstabiliser
Kasparov lui-même donc tout est possible
alors ensuite dans la partie qui opposé
nos deux précédents vainqueurs de de
Grand Prix du Sénat et du Grand Prix de
Bordeaux entre donc Alexe Shirov et
Michael Adams partie nulle donc les deux
vainqueurs se neutralis oui partie nul
ils arrivent pas à se départager mais
cependant shirof a quand même pris
l'initiative dans cette partie il a eu
un pion de plus il n'a pas réussi à
transformer l'essai il a donc dominé
Michael Adams dans cette première partie
mais ça c'est un peu le le point faible
de Shirov je dirais puisque à linarest
c'était pareil il n'arrivait pas à
conclure les positions gagnantes et ça
ça lui joue des tours il faut vraiment
qu'il fasse un effort de concentration
d'application ou simplement de travail
de technique je ne sais pas il faut
qu'il trouve une solution pour gagner
les positions gagnantes ou en tout cas
transformer les essais puisque que là il
se freine tout seul là oui là il se
vraiment il s'arnaque tout seul pour
ainsi dire oui enfin donc dernière nul
Sokolov contre barayev partie nulle donc
une partie tranquille partie tranquille
oui c'est donc Sokolov a joué assez
solide bon barayf est satisfait par la
nulle donc une nulle très logique donc
ce qui nous donne un classement avec
donc quatre paquets de quatre joueur
enfin trois paquet de quatre joueurs
donc avec en tête Kasparov ça y qu'il se
détache tout de suite et bon mais
Étienne qui donc maintenant va doit
surmonter une défaite ce qui est
toujours psychologiquement difficile
ouis ououi tout à fait d'ailleurs au
moment où on enregistre cette mission il
est en train de souffrir contre son
adversaire de la deuxième ronde qui est
donc Kiril gorgief avec les Blancs il a
sacrifié un pion et là il a une position
difficile à tenir il y a eu beaucoup de
nul aujourd'hui euh autre partie il y a
eu également donc Kasparov contre Adams
donc la partie partie choc ouais partie
choc et partie partie intéressante où
casparov a une qualité de plus on en
sait pas plus pour l'instant il a il
réussi à avoir une tour contre une pièce
mineure mais un pion de moins oui alors
partie très très surprenante honnêtement
je n'ai pas bien compris ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie euh vous verrez
ça dans le flash de vendredi matin si
vous revenez encore dans les différés
euh là Kasparov avait l'air complètement
gagnant il avait un pion de plus
tranquille ensuite il a pris une qualité
mais ça ça s'est transformé les pions
ont été échangés bref une partie qui s
qui s'achemine vers la nulle à partir de
maintenant donc peut-être erreur de
Kasparov ou en tout cas Adams très très
tenonas alors on va venir maintenant
tout de suite à notre deuxème rubrique
de la journée avec la partie de la
semaine partie de la semaine donc entre
Kasparov et bakro
[Musique]
voilà donc cette partie de la semaine
donc entre Kasparov et bakro voilà si on
peut mettre les ch est en plein
écran donc Gary Kasparov àz blanc contre
Étienne bakro tout de suite ça démarre
avec le coup E4 et réponse d'Étienne par
E5 alors pourquoi ce choix pourquoi ce
choix alors Étienne joue très bien la
sicil également E45 c'est plus solide et
il ça fait partie de son répertoire
actuel d'ouverture sur la Sicilienne il
a remporté des victoires brillantes il
joue très très bien cette ouverture mais
contre Gary Kasparov jouer E4 C5 il faut
quand même du courage puisqueon risque
quand même de de subir une préparation
théorique intense et avec Kasparov ça
sera forcément le cas donc ktienne ici
préfère jouer sur le terrain du jeu
d'écheac tout simplement et non pas sur
le terrain de la préparation c'est vrai
que c'est c'est un choix assez logique
dans la mesure où personne n'a envie
d'affronter Kasparov sur la préparation
dans les ouvertures ou alors c'est du
ressort de kramnick ou Anand en tout cas
il faut une préparation vraiment du du
top mondial pour pouvoir jouer la
Sicilienne contre gar Kasparov donc ici
Étienne bakro joue au 45 vous voyez les
pions là c'est symétriqu ça veut dire
que Etienne bakro cherche à égaliser il
ne cherche pas de de de déséquilibre il
cherche pas à créer une tension un
climat tendu dès le début il cherche à
calmer le jeu ça c'est clair donc après
cavalier F3 coup logique ettienne
choisit cavalier C6 il aurait pu opter
pour une défense Pétrof qui est
peut-être plus annulante la défense
petof est plus annulante mais ne fait
pas encore partie du répertoire
d'Étienne donc il faut pas non plus
jouer quelque chose qu'on a jamais vu il
il a je pense qu'il a fait un bon choix
d'ouverture de toute façon il a des très
bons entraîneurs qui ont dû le le lui
recommander de jouer cette cette
ouverture avec K6 au deième coup il faut
jouer il fallait trouver un juste milieu
entre un terrain qui soit pas trop
analysé pas trop théorique et non plus
un terrain que Étienne connaisse donc
choix très logique à mon avis et là Gary
Kasparov a le choix entre fou B5 coup
qui l'affectionne et le coup d pour
l'espagnol ou alors D2 D4 le coup de la
partie qui est la partie écossaise la
partie écossaise qui a été mise à la
mode par casparov lui-même c'est quand
même une référence dans son match contre
carpof cont oui contre carpof lui-même
il avait remporté une belle victoire il
avait remis au bout du jour
c'est un début qui avait pas été joué en
championnat du monde je crois jamais
avant Kasparov ça n'avait jamais été
joué en Championnat du Monde oui
incroyable donc cette défense écossaise
donc on va dire les les idées un peu de
l'ouverture bon évidemment les blancs
font quand même deux coups très logiques
E4 et D4 ça prend le centre c'est très
bien pourquoi parce que bon il faut
toujours bouger ces deux pions pour
sortir les fous tout simplement et quand
on a quand on a sorti le fou F1 jouer le
petit rock donc ça c'est l'ouverture en
général maintenant le jouer dans cette
position ça ça n'a pas que des avantages
puisque ça permet au noir de gagner du
temps puisque après eux prend des4 qui
est le coup connu et reconnu cavalier
prend des4 les Noirs jouent cavalier F6
il y a le choix également avec fou C5
mais en tout cas ici ils attaquent le
pion E4 et donc commencec à gagner du
temps cavier prend C6 très logique
Kasparov connaît très bien très bien
cette position c'est le coup théorique B
prend C6 tout à fait normal là E5 coup
théorique aussi on attaque le cavalier
tout ça c'est c'est très très théorique
je vous invite donc à regarder dans les
archives la partie morozevic contre
xillone ouis qui est également cette
ouverture là très VI une très vieille
émission hein c'est une émission qui
date d'il y a plus d'un an c'est une
très très vieille émission c'était le
tournois de pampeloun euh de Noël
dernier donc c'est voilà c'était avant
Noël c'était avant Noël ou donc c'est
une très vieille émission mais
effectivement vous pouvez la retrouver
dans les archives de diagonale donc
l'ouverture est analysé plus très en
détail là-bas donc on va pas non plus
refaire les mêm commentair dame 7 dame 2
donc dame 7 a eu un clouage dame 2
cavalier D5 et au 8e coup les Blancs
jouent C4 et là on arrive à
l'embranchement l'embranchement où les
Noirs ont le choix entre plusieurs
possibilités donc le cavalier est
attaqué le P C4 attaque le C D5 donc
deux possibilités soit ce cavalier
déménage et va sur la case B6 soit le
fou C8 vient sur la case A6 et effectue
un clouage c'est qu'il va clouer le pion
C4 si le pion prend le cavalier la dame
serait perdu donc c'est pas c'est pas un
coup à faire ça c'est les deux choix
carpof avait expérimenté les deux avait
fait un point sur de un demi Pointin sur
de il avait fait une nulle et une perte
ici ettian choisit le coup à la mode
théoriquement c'est fou à 6 pourquoi
c'est plus à la mode simplement parce
que c'est plus logique le cavalier en D5
est très bien placé et en plus donc on
le défend indirectement on évite de s'
de de partir de cette case clé et en
même temps on développe une pièce très
très important donc là le coup B3 qui a
pour but à la fois de consolider le pion
C4 et aussi de sortir le fou sur la case
B2 oui l'enjeu de cette position c'est
le pion E5 est-ce que les blancs vont
réussir à conserver ce pion E5 ça c'est
c'est tout l'enjeu de de cette partie
les Noirs ont sorti deux pièces de plus
que les Blancs la question c'est est-ce
qu'ils vont réussir à déstabiliser ce
pion de cette case alors donc B3 est
très logique puisque effectivement ça
défense C4 mais ça c'est un effet annexe
l'idée principale c'est de mettre le fou
C1 en B 2 pour commencer à blinder cette
case ensuite on a d'autres plans qui
seront par exemple sortir le cavalier B1
pour le mettre en D2 puis en F3 là ça
défendra également notre point critique
qui est ce pion E5 donc B3 très logique
encore de la théorie toujours de la
théorie G6 logique également puisque si
les blancs veulent le défendre les Noirs
veulent l'attaquer tout ça c'est très
c'est très très simple donc c'est pour
mettre le fou sur la case G7 afin
d'attaquer le pion E5 euh donc comme ça
on défend on attaque une fois de plus et
il faudra les blanc défendent oui pour
généraliser effectivement ce pion E5 il
faut toujours attaquer la pièce ennemi
la plus avancée donc là en l'occurrence
c'est le pion5 ce qui ce qui explique
pourquoi ce principe et là Caspar
choisit une solution radicale pour
défendre son pion c'est le défendre par
un autre pion ce qui est toujours la
solution la plus économique c'est
économique bon alors maintenant ça a des
inconvénients c'estd que ça a l'air
parfait le pion 5 est bien défendu le
revers de la médaille c'est que ça n'a
toujours pas sorti de pièce et que
éventuellement ce pion F4 peut être en
prise donc maintenant il y a plus de
foussé un B2 qui tiennent puisque le C
D5
évidemment sauterit sur le pion F4 donc
ça ça a des inconvénients les Blancs
n'ont toujours pas sorti de pièces quand
même on peut remarquer ça c'est c'est
assez euh c'est assez surprenant surtout
de la part d'un joueur actif comme
casparof et là Étienne choisit là encore
il fait un choix est-ce que il aurait pu
jouer fou G6 peut-être dans cette
position ou alors éventuellement fou G7
euh g pard peut-être il me semble que le
coup G6 G5 existe mais je n'en suis pas
complètement sûr euh ça aurait fait
l'objet d'un débat théorique c'est à
vérifier euh maintenant bon probablement
il y a des coups très logiques à
envisagés il y a CAV D5 en B6 il y a
grand ro il y a D7 D6 il y a plusieurs
coups possibles non D7 D6 n'est pas bon
mais grand R fou G7 ou k B6 sont les
trois coups à envisager ettienne joue un
coup qui m'a un peu surpris il joue dame
E7 en B4 échaque
au donc ça a l'air d'être un bon coup
puisque ça ça va permettre de sortir le
fou F8
probablement aussi sur une case en7 par
exemple ou en B4 peut-être ou en C5
enfin en tout cas en tout cas et en tout
cas ça pose le problème au blanc échec
ça pose le problème échec effectivement
après le coup F4 l'idée des noirs de
sortir le fou sur la case G7 est un peu
passé de mode puisque le pion E5 est
déjà complètement défendu donc dame B4
échec Gary Kasparov jou fou D2 et
maintenant la dame trouve un poste assez
agréable en B6 évidemment un
inconvénient c'est que maintenant le
cavalier D5 ne pourra plus y aller donc
très vite Gary Kasparov exploite ce
phénomène et attaque le cavalier tout
simplement en déclouant le P C4 c'estàd
que là la dame est en prise par le fou à
6 si jamais on essaie de prendre le C D5
donc après le coup dame 4 voilà ça y est
le cavalier maintenant est réellement en
prise puceque le fou A6 ne taperait plus
sur la dame mais je pense ici qu'on peut
déjà faire plus ou moins un petit bilan
c'est que l'attaque des noirs sur le
pion E5 a complètement échoué ça c'est
une première remarque maintenant il y a
plus aucune pièce qui attaque ce pion
donc déjà raté maintenant l'autre
l'autre chose c'est que les Blancs ont
commencé à sortir leur pièces donc là
Étienne est obligé de trouver un coup de
pour justifier ce qui vient de se passer
parce que sinon c'est pas bon ça aura
tout simplement échoué ouais parce qu'il
a pas trop le choix là son cavalier a
pas de case euh on voit pas où il peut
le mettre s'il le met sur la case B4 on
a l'impression que le coup A2 à3 tout
simplement gagne le cavalier exactement
donc ici cavalier B4 est impossible
puisqu'il y A2 A3 qui enferme la pièce
c'estd qu'il attaque et la pièce n'a pas
de case cavalier E7 c'est un coup
absolument horrible on n pas envie de
jouer cavalier e 7 donc Étienne est en
train de mettre un peu le feu à la
position avec le coup F7 F5 qui permet
donc une prise en passant avec échec
donc alors voyons un peu ce que
donnerait la prise en passant qui n'a
pas été jouée dans la partie voilà prise
en passant en F6 échec au roi avec la
dame ici les rois le les Noirs jouerai
le coup roi F7 et là la menace c'est
tour E8 tour A8 en E8 donc clou la dame
donc le C D5 ne peut toujours pas être
pris pour cette raisonl et ici les noir
obtienent une très très grosse activité
puisque tour 8 est inévitable et
maintenant le cavalier va à trouver une
case maintenant de c'est la case F6 il
va reprendre le pion F6 il va reprendre
le pion F6 ou alors de toute façon après
tour E8 il y aura également la case B4
qui commencera à être disponible pour
chatouiller le roi le roi blanc en C2
donc beaucoup de possibilités Kasparov
n'accepte pas ça d'autant plus que c'est
une concession stratégique grave que
donn P5 donc alors après le coup F5 joué
par Étienne gar Kasparov replie sa dame
et va sur la case F3 voilà un coup plus
logique un coup plus logique et ici
Étienne joue dame B6 en D4 toujours sur
le même principe qu' il a pas envie de
déplacer son cahette D5 et en plus donc
là il attaque la tour qui n'a pas de
case donc on peut supposer qu'Étienne
est toujours dans sa préparation à ce
niveau-là alors ça a déjà été joué cette
partie est encore théorique jusqu'ici
donc évidemment il est très probable que
les deux joueurs soient encore dans leur
préparation bon ça c'est la magie de la
préparation des ouvertures tout le monde
est surentraîné maintenant et tout le
monde connaît toutes les parties qui
sont joué grâce à l'Internet donc c'est
très très dur de surprendre dans les
ouvertures surtout Kasparov surtout
Kasparov qui est lui vraiment très très
fort dans ce domaine donc la dév
casparov et en même temps il part la
menace contre la tour et c'était
quasiment coup forcé Caval C3 CP forcé
ou Caval C3 Étienne échange les pièce
cavalier prend fou prend donc il a
résolu le problème de son cavalier il a
résolu le problème de son cavalier
maintenant le problème dans cette
position c'est que les Blancs
positionnellement ont une meilleure
structure de pion vous voyez qu'ils ont
que deux paquets de pions he il y en a
un qui est là avec trois pions l'autre
avec quatre pions ça c'est des pions qui
sont tous liés et qui se tiennent alors
que pour les Noirs c'est plus délicat il
y a un pion tout seul en A7 un deuxème
bloc en rouge et un troisème bloc ici et
le deuxième bloc et en plus des pions
doublés ce qui est toujours difficile à
bouger difficile à mettre en en manœuvre
le gros problème des pions doublés c'est
nimzovic qui l'a dit ce n'est pas en
défense c'est en attaque c'estàd qu'on
ne peut rien en faire ils sont
inexploitables en attaque en défense
c'est bien il contrôle beaucoup de cas
ça va en attaque c'est pas bon du tout
alors là donc il y a un gros problème
pour Étienne c'est dire qu'il a réussi à
échanger des pièces à simplifier la
position malheureusement il est quand
même rester avec avec tous les soucis de
cette ouverture notamment le pion E5 qui
est très très fort dans cette position
donc il joue un joli coup maintenant
enfin qui est qui est esthétique en tout
cas le coup fou B4 parce qu'il y a un
double clouage maintenant qui s'instaore
oui c'est le célèbre double clouage
alors c'est un très joli thème euh
puisque vous voyez que le fou B4 est en
prise et la dame D4 aussi ouais donc le
fou C3 est susceptible de prendre les
deux pièces malheureusement il ne peut
en prendre aucune des deux puisque s'il
prend la dame c'est le roi qui se
retrouve en prise donc c'est interdit
donc c'est pas bon donc la dame est pas
vraiment en prise en fait et s'il prend
le fou c'est la tour qui se retrouve en
prise ouis et avec échec c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait on a voilà les pièces clou
sont à prendre mais les pièces clouées
sont plus importantes que les pièces
clouantes c'est pas clair mais c'est le
en gros pour exposer un peu ce qui ce
qui se passe dans cette position c'est
que le fou C3 est attaqué et ne peut pas
bouger donc ça pose un petit problème à
Gary Kasparov qui doit donc
défendre il a tout prévu donc il joue
tour C tranquillement et ça y est il
défend son fou et maintenant il menace
de prendre de faire le coup fou prend
fou B4 puisqueant sa tour n'est plus
attaquer voilà donc tour attaque et
défend à la fois c'est très bien F prend
c3ti échange des pièces tour prend C3
donc là bilan il faut s'arrêter bon il
fallait pas jouer dame prend C3 dans
cette position on va y revenir au 16e
coup des noirs sur dame prend C3 donc au
coup blanc c'est une faute puisqueaprès
dame prend dame tour prend les Noirs
jouent le coup libérateur C6 C5 suivi de
fou fou A6 en B7 et là il y aura plus de
problème absolument pour tenir cette
finale donc Gary Kasparov en ce moment
le nouvel enjeu de la position
maintenant que Gary kasperov a réussi à
prendre cette case 5 à stabiliser son
pion sur cette case il vaut empêcher les
noirs de jouer le coup C6 C5 qui
donnerait une belle diagonale au fou
noir qui pour l'instant est en muré par
les pions blancs le fou noir n'est pas
très bien placé effectivement le le coup
libérateur pour les Noirs dans cette
position c'est C6 C5 donc évidemment
Gary Kasparov joue tour prend C3 puisque
le pion C6 ne peut pas avancer à cause
de ce clouage clouage mortel donc la
tour A8 est en prise et maintenant
Étienne choisit le grand roquet alors
est-ce qu'il aurait pas pu choisir à ce
niveau-là le petit rock plutôt c'est
deux coups deux coups possibles euh en
principe alors là je pense qu'il a dû
suivre un principe général pour jouer
Grand Roc il faut amener le roi du côté
où les pions sont le plus faible alors
là clairement euh c'est euh la zone ici
hein qu'on va pointer en rouge ces
quatre pions là rouge sont assez faibles
donc il faut amener le roi du côté où
les pions sont faibles d'autant plus que
sur le petit rock il y aurait des
possibilités d'attaque pour Gary
Kasparov simplement en envoyant le
bélier H2 H4 H5 euh qui ouvrirait la
colonne de la tour H1 ici donc gar CASP
fa eu des moyens d'attaquer le le roi
d'Étienne donc là non seulement il va du
côté de ses faiblesses mais en plus il
va du côté où il a son fou qui est là
pour le défendre le fou en A6 donc grand
rock est plus logique que petit Ro et
c'est là que Gary trouve un superbe coup
vraiment une conception
magnifique donc là il bloque il va il va
empêcher le coup libérateur des Noirs en
fait en jouant le coup au 18e coup le
coup C5 mais qui permet quand même au
fou noir de de s'échanger contre le fou
F1 oui alors ça c'est le revers de la
médaille bon maintenant effectivement
après ce coup C4 C5 il a empêché
radicalement les Noirs au 18 cou de
jouer C6 C5 au 18e coup ça c'est le le
coup clé c'est vraiment le coup donc si
si on a suivi la partie en direct sur
Internet c'est le coup qui a échappé un
peu à à toute la population il y avait
200 personnes présentes sur le sur le
chat de cette partie et donc personne
n'avait vraiment envisager C5 où
personne n'avait vraiment mesuré le
poids de ce coup il y avait des grands
matres il y avait des matres il y avait
beaucoup de monde et ça ça là c'est
vraiment la la patte d'un grand champion
puisque C4 C5 je pense que c'est
vraiment le coup qui qui stabilise
l'avantage des blancs et qui fait que
les Noirs maintenant sont cantonnés à
une défense passive en plus la réaction
d'Étienne a été catastrophique tout
simplement oui donc Étienne joue le coup
maintenant 18e coup fou B7 et alors là
on peut se demander s'il aurait pas
mieux fait de prendre le fou F1 parce
que ce fou en B7 maintenant que le coup
C6 C5 n'est pas possible on voit
pourquoi c'était intéressant de le jouer
c'est que ce fou n'a aucun avenir voilà
alors c'est très curieux c'est très
curieux quand même de la part d'Étienne
de ramener son fou A6 en B7 alors que
maintenant les perspectives de jouer
lui-même C6 C5 sont complètement arrêtés
n'existe plus donc dans cette position
on va y revenir au 18e coup évidemment
le coup critique c'était fou pr fou fou
pr fou donc qui serait suivi par tour
prfou et ici bon dans cette finale on
peut toujours espérer espérer tenir avec
les Noirs simplement pour une raison
très simple c'est que les blancs vont
être obligés d'échanger la dame noire
elle est trop forte en D4 donc il va ça
va être une finale de tour et dans la
finale de tour le roi en C8 va défendre
les pions du côté du côté gauche de
l'chiquier donc de l' l' roi des Noirs
maintenant euh et ça ça aurait pu tenir
maintenant avec le fou en B7 c'est plus
délicat c'est plus délicat parce que
justement les Blancs jouent avec un fou
de plus tout simplement ils ont un gros
pion ici les noirs on peut considérer ce
fou comme étant un gros pion il n'a
aucune activité il ne pourra plus jamais
revenir sur la case à 6 et et là il ne
passera pas ouais donc fou B7 grosse
faute positionnelle et très très
surprenante de la part d'Étienne qui est
quand même un joueur très talentueux au
niveau positionnel donc je n'arrive pas
à expliquer ça mais c'est vrai que je me
suis jamais non plus retrouvé en face de
garyry Kasparov et d'après les les
analyses postmem semble-t-il des deux
joueurs le coup F pr ne présager rien de
bon non plus les Noirs étaient quand
même étouffés par ce coup C4 C5 et les
plans avaient un blanc les blancs aussi
avaient un plan possible qui était avec
à base de tour F2 et tour D2 pour
chasser la dame et qui pouvait s'avérer
aussi dangereux alors effectivement
j'étais pas informé par par ces analyses
postmortem qui éclairent un peu tout
cependant F fin était quand même
préférable pour ne serait-ce que pour
alléger un peu la tension et simplement
tout VO on va voir que effectivement
çaou alors c'est là que ça se transforme
en leçon de technique je crois voilà
leçon technique maintenant de Gary
Kasparov il a tous les avantages la
position et joue avec un fou
virtuellement un fou de plus
virtuellement fout de plus et il échange
les dames donc voilà il n'a pas le temps
de de faire cette manœuvre tour F1 F2 D2
manœuvre qui aurait chassé la dame
simplement ici il dit d'accord ben
maintenant je suis prêt pour l'échange
des dames donc cette dame en D4 m'ennuie
je vais proposer l'échange donc dame
prend dame accepté par Étienne tour
prend E3 et là il faut se libérer avec
les noirs on peut pas tolérer cette
formation complètement aberrante de de
pion ici le pion D7 arriéré tout ça
c'est pas bon donc Étienne tente le
libérateur D7 D6 et là Gary impérial lui
dit et bien bon tu attaques mon pion C5
mais je m'en fous complètement
ouais je joue 21 fou C4 et maintenant
c'est là qu'on voit c'est là qu'on voit
que le coup pion C5 serait serait
sanctionné par une une structure de pion
désastreuse et je pense en plus que ça
serait sanctionné par un gain immédiat
de qualité simplement après l'avancée du
pion e donc c'est une variante voilà non
ce n'est pas ça le pion le coup E7 E6 E5
E6 je
mè suivi de E7 dans cette position enfin
peut-être enfin en tout cas
c'est euh E6 suivi de roi F2 ou roi E2
euh ici il y aurait eu des des belles
perspectives pour les blancs avec un
pion passé ici qui n'est pas bloqué et
ce qu'on voit c'est que
positionnellement ça ce n'est pas une
position raisonnable oui tout à fait
c'est des pions qui sont amené de toute
façon à mourir tôt ou tard oui donc
après fou C4 Étienne ne veut pas jouer
ce déprend C5 euh catastrophique
catastrophique puisque tous les pions
seraient bloqués et triplés donc c'est
pas très joli il joue roi D7 amenant le
roi en jeu et là Gary doncess de
colmater un peu les brèches ouais mais
là c'est là trop tard puisque Gary est
déjà prêt à ouvrir un nouveau front
c'est-à-dire que là il a déjà pris tous
les avantages le fou B7 est horors jeu
c'est le moment d'ouvrir la position de
l'autre côté et là Gary il va il va
tranquille H2 H4 en plus et en plus il
met ses pions sur la couleur opposée à
celle de son fou ce qui est toujours une
bonne chose ça c'est discutable mais
effectivement dans en principe général
c'est surtout valable en principe de
enfin dans les finales de fou
quand il y a plus de tour là il faut
impérativement faire une complémentarité
entre le fou et les pions quand c'est
avec encore des tours si le fou noir par
exemple était sur la case E4 on serait
pas mé content d'avoir un pion F5 mais
là effectivement dans ce cas-là le fou
noir n'a plus aucune chance de revenir
le coup H2 H4 est très agressif et en
plus met un pion sur case noir donc fait
une complémentarité avec le fou ettienne
ici craque il craque il craque il y a
pas d'autre explication 22e coup il joue
D6 5 se fermant les dernières
possibilités qu'il avait d'ouvrir le jeu
donc Gary Kasparov se replie fou D3 et
H5 c'est qui craque dans le sens où il
va se maintenant se cantonner à une
défense passive là dans cette position
il a fermé tous les fronts on voit que
le foot Gary Kasparov ne peut plus
attaquer directement les pions d'Étienne
qui sont dans la structure antifou la
structure dite antifou avec les pions
qui se tiennent comme ça très logique
donc là le fou gar kaspov est neutralisé
cependant il y a plus aucune perspective
pour dans cette position son pion G6
donc là il faut voir comment en fait ce
qui est intéressant de voir c'est
comment comment Gary Kasparov arrive à
transformer cet avantage d'espace et de
structure en gain parce que là c'est de
la technique c'est la technique à l'état
pure quoi c'est de la technique à l'état
pure la position est probablement
gagnante ici mais effectivement il faut
encore il faut encore le faut trouver le
plan et ensuite les coups ou oui et oui
faut trouver les idées donc ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas si simple donc je pense
qu'on va on peut détailler le plan pour
voir ensuite la réalisation la
réalisation technique teque c'est que le
roi de E1 va monter vers la case D4 ça
c'est c'est une certitude ouis parce
qu'il sera beaucoup plus actif il sera
actif il sera prêt il sera au centre il
est dominant il est rayonnant donc c'est
là qu'il faut l'amener il va
probablement mettre une tour en G3 et
essayer de mettre l'autre tour pour
attaquer le pion A7 c'estd qu'en fait là
bon voilà ça fait un peu fouiller sur
l'écran mais en gros il va mettre le roi
au centre et mettre les tours sur les
colonnes où ça attaquera les deux pions
les deux cibles qu'on va mettre en rouge
maintenant qui sont les pions A7 et G6
ça c'est les deux cibles donc il va
pilonner toutes ses cibles et à la fin
comme il a plus d'espace et plus de
mobilité il va tourner dans les deux
sens un coup à droite un coup à gauche
et là normalement si tout se passe bien
pour les blancs et bien Etienne ne
pourra pas tourner aussi vite puisqu'il
a moins de place moins d'espace de
manœuvre donc ça c'est le plan
généraland pingpong quoi oui c'est ça il
va le décaler décaler gauche droite
gauche droite et à un moment il fera un
contrepied et ça sera terminé tour G3
tour H6 coup assez horrible mais
probablement le sol dans cette position
B4 donc là il fixe Gary CASP fixe le
pion en A7 il veut éviter qu'Étienne
puisse jouer A7 à5 ça c'est un
remarquable geste technique est-ce que
Étienne pourrait pas quand même jouer le
coup à 7 à 5 tout de suite sacrifiant ce
pion pour activer sa tour oui c'est une
possibilité intéressante oui oui tout à
fait j'avais pas envisagé que ça soit
possible effectivement peut-être
peut-être qu'Étienne avait une carte à
jouer ici avec le coup à 7 à 5
peut-être peut-être c'est une
possibilité parce que si le alors je
sais pas ce que peuvent faire les blancs
parce que peut-être peut-être tout
simplement jouer à 2 à 3 ils sont
peut-être pas obligés de prendre un à 5
oui mais al ce momentl c'est une
victoire complète pour les noir puisque
on échangerait le pion a 7 qui était
faible contre le pion A2 qui était très
bien et puis on va activer la tour et en
plus on va jouer tour à8 tout de suite
après ou et sur pion prend pion on joue
tour à8 quand même et ça a l'air de
s'activer donc ici peut-être
effectivement voilà tu tu me tu peux
prend au dépourvu peut-être une
possibilité une possibilité peut-être de
défense pour Étienne mais c'est
difficile quand on est dans ce genre de
position hyper passive de commencer à
jouer un coup réactif mais peut-être
tout simplement la tour peut pas
s'activer facilement parce que les les
blancs vont vont vont pilonner sur la
case G6 il va falloir les de les deux
tours pour pour protéger ce pion oui bah
tu as dit la solution d'ailleurs c'est
que dans la position précédente voilà
sur le coup à 5 il y aurait probablement
tour prend G6 à un moment ou un autre
qui gagne tout de suite toute la maison
donc là Gary CASP fait une menace
directe en fait menace Tourp G6 non
alors j'ai l'impression que je suis en
train de m'enfoncer je suis en train de
menfoncer non non mais peut-être
peut-être en fait c'est c'est peut-être
pas une libération possible pour les
Noirs euh parce que s'ils activent leur
tour à gauche ils auront pas les moyens
après de se défendre à droite oui oui ça
c'est c'est une possibilité en tout cas
A5 était possible semble c'est un coup
raisonnable qui n'est pas n'est pas
inintéressant absolument roi E6 joué par
Gary euh joué par Étienne jou par
Étienne ro des de maintenant c'est Gary
casptien joue tour à 8 on a l'impression
qu'il veut jouer euh la possibilité
après tour à 8 26e coup la possibilité
de jouer à 7 à 5 là qui est en donc
c'est un peu dans l'idée de ce qu'on
disait il aurait peut-être pu le faire
au coup précédent mais
euh là il y a un coup voilà il a tourb1
il y a tour B1 donc sur sur A7 à5 puis
on prend
A5 attaque le fou B7 attaque le fou B7
et effectivement après fou A6 donc la
variante pour ceux qui suivent un petit
peu fou PR 6 tour pr a 6 tour B8
activité je ne sais pas effectivement à
5 est encore à l'ordre du jour de toute
façon il faut pas mépriser ce coup mais
Étienne continue à jouer extrêmement
passif alors peut-être qu'il s'est dit
tout simplement et bien Gary viens me
chercher j'ai pas besoin de jouer à 5 je
n'ai besoin de rien dans cette
position je vais défendre toutes mes fa
C 5 était une possibilité pour Étienne
en tout cas le C 5 était une possibilité
oui alors ici Gary casparov joue tour B3
va commencer à attaquer le pion à6
ettienne n'a plus trop de coup joue ro
F7 tour à3 très logique donc ça y est
Gary Caspar est en train de fixer les
pièces noires donc là c'est une vraie
démonstration puisque maintenant que
tout est fixe voilà tour H8 il a réussi
à libérer sa tour tour G5 on ne sait pas
trop à quoi ça sert mais c'est Al tour
G5 ça peut être alors moi je je vois je
connais un peu je peut-être l'idée c'est
dans certaines variantes si la tour H8
s'en va de jouer le coup G2 G4 oui avec
si les Noirs prennent on peut jouer H4
H5 ou alors F4 F5 et on ramassera tous
les pions au final oui tout à fait ouai
ça ça c'est une des idées possibles ou
c'est une des idées possibles de tour G5
l'autre idée l'autre idée étant de
pouvoir amener l'autre tour sur la case
G3 pour doubler les tours donc un
maximum de soupl g ne se dépêche pas
d'amener son roi de D2 en D4 il il prend
tout son temps on peut le dire tour H6
ettienne revient donc là c'est c'est
malheureux roi C3 tour B8 tour A5 donc
là gar l'empêche complètement de bouger
et menace maintenant fou point à 6 qui
n'était pas possible avant à cause de
tour à 8 retour avec clouage donc ici
tour à 8 semble forcé roi D4 ça y est il
a activé son roi comme on avait dit tout
à l'heure il AER son roi vers le centre
si vous voyez la transformation entre
cette position et celle qu'on avait
quelques coups plut tôt c'est tout à
fait un incroyable ce que Gary a
amélioré sa position tour h H8 fou C2
voilà alors là libérant le passage pour
passer soit comme ça soit comme ça
c'est-à-dire chaque tour peut venir
aider l'autre donc là c'est vraiment une
c'est une leçon en fa coulisse il
coulisse là ou ou il est il est
extrêmement mobile dans cette position
tour ab8 c'est que les noirs on voit
bien que les noirs sont un peu
impuissants ils attendent de voir ce que
vont faire les blancs fou D3 Gary
Kasparov revient donc logiquement
Étienne aussi et maintenant CASP change
c'estàd qu' vraiment il est très calme
dans cette position il peut jouer un peu
ce qu'il veut donc là il a répété une
fois la position ou en fait mais
finalement il choisit de mettre son fou
sur la case2 plutôt que C2 il a trouvé
il a trouvé une idée il a trouvé une
idée alors ici donc les pièces d'Étienne
sont fixées à la défense de pion à 6
tour hb8 voilà Étienne se dit je vais
peut-être réagir je vais peut-être jouer
un coup comme fou C8 c'est c'est c'est
possible il s'est peut-être dit ça mais
tour à3 donc là la menace effectivement
c'est de revenir sur cette case G3 pour
ramasser le pion G6 et si on si on prend
le pion G6 tous les autres pions tombent
puisqu'ils sont faibles isolés et en
plus sous la couleur du Fou ennemi voilà
c'est exactement ça donc Étienne
continue dans son esprit de défense
passive tour H8 Gary CASP joue tour AG3
donc là menace clairement Tourp G6 tour
point G6 et la menace tourage G8 et
maintenant le final les blancs jou
gagnent les blancs jouets gagnent donc
prenez quelques secondes regardez
tranquillement cette position et voyez
si vous arriverez si vous arriveriez à
conclure cette partie aussi bien que laa
fait Gary Kasparov
on va compter jusqu'à 5 5 5 voilà donc
ici 39e coup superbe combinette F pr h
pr H5 F prend H5 et alors là ça c'est
Étienne Bro abandonne tout de suite
parce que là le pion G6 va tomber si on
reprend pas le fou et si on prend le fou
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors deux
possibilités pour reprendre le fou il y
a tour prend H5 et pion prend H5 et les
deux sont les deux sont perdantes alors
commençons par le coup tour point H5
voilà voilà c'est une possibilité mais
alors là il y a un coup un coup très
fort dans cette position c'est le coup
E5 E6 échec roi F8 est forcé et
maintenant e67 et on force les Noirs à
prendre ce pion qui devenait trop
dangereux et maintenant on fait tour pr
tour et on a gagné la qualité on a gagné
une qualité tranquille et le fou noir
est toujours en plus dans sal état donc
ça c'est clairement gagnant donc ici
tour prend H5 n'est pas un bon coup
l'autre possibilité c'est g prend H5 et
la même idée et là on refait la même
idée c'est-à-dire le coup E6 dans cette
position E6
échec là pas vraiment de choix pour les
Noirs il faut jouer un mauvais coup r F8
par exemple on continue avec E7 échec on
fait diversion deux possibilités si le
roi vient en F7 on va prendre toutes les
tours et faire dame et si le roi prend
le pion E7 comme on voit ici hop on
prend une tour simplement tour prend
tour et on a une qualité encore une fois
avec une position écrasante oui puisque
le fou restaurant en B7 et donc va se
faire manger par cette simple manœuvre
de tour qui va ramasser toute la baraque
donc tour fou H5 la combinaison finale
on va revenir sur cette position finale
qui est donc vraiment une démonstration
technique et pousouflante de Gary
Kasparov vraiment très très bien joué de
la part de Kasparov oui très très belle
très très belle réalisation voilà on va
passer maintenant donc après cette
brillante analyse de cette partie donc
de Kasparov contre Étienne Bro la trè
rubrique avec donc l'actualité de la
semaine
[Musique]
voilà l'actualité de la semaine alors
d'abord une nouvelle qui peut être
intéressante c'est que le prochain
Championnat du Monde d'échec aura lieu
d'après le dernier congrès la FIDÉ à la
fois en Inde et en Iran c'est surprenant
c'est surprenant mais politiquement ces
pays semblent assez isolés notamment
l'Iran ouais surtout l'Iran ouais
surtout l'Iran donc bon Kersan juminov
toujours à la recherche d'un site pour
organiser son championnat du monde enfin
d'un site physique je dirais d'un site
terrain a semble-t-il trouver l'Iran qui
serait prêt à organiser le Championnat
du Monde qui est confirmé donc il paraît
que l'argent est à la banque les fameux
3 millions de dollars de prix pour les
joueurs d'écheac pour les 100 meilleurs
joueurs du monde qui vont se partager la
cagnotte en fonction de leur résultat
c'est toujours le système élimination
directe et il semblerait donc le
championnat soit confirmé pour cette
année en Iran et donc à des dates qui
sont fait année je crois en fin d'année
donc on verra on verra ça
euh ensuite deuxième information donc
intéressante c'est il y a un un un
mémorial de Leonid Stein qui était un
grand joueur qui se déroule
donc actuellement avec la présence de
grand joueurs dont Vasili vanchou dont
on avait parlé lors de tour de Monaco un
des meilleurs joueurs du monde encore
une fois qui est en tête oui Vassili
vanchou toujours en quête de partie
longue qui qui est très très fort euh
qui n'aime pas les smin rapides parce
qu'il trouve que son jeu devient VI
imparfait donc c'est le c'est l'artiste
du jeu d'échec c'est le c'est Yvan chou
c'est la classe c'est celui qui veut
toujours jouer les meilleurs coups et là
il est servi et d'ailleurs il est en
pleine forme c'est un peu le fou des
échecs aussi on peut dire ça c'est le le
prophète du il a fait une belle partie
contre corchno c'est ça il a fait une
belle partie il a battu Victor corchnoy
à la 5è ronde très belle partie et donc
ça l'a propulsé en tête du classement
seul détaché avec 4 points sur 5 ce qui
est évidemment un score fleuve donc ça
c'était pour le Leonin tournament alors
ce qui é intéressant aussi c'est le
tournoi de New York alors tournoi de New
York avec donc victoire de smirine
victoire de l'Israélien Ilias smirine
qui domine le tournoi qui gagne ses
trois dernières rondes donc dans un
tournoi Open c'est très important de
gagner les dernières parties ici il a il
a simplement battu tout le monde à la
fin le Russe Galkin à la dernière ronde
ce qu'il a propulsé avec 7 et demi sur 9
à la première place tout seul il a
empoché au passage le premier prix du
tournoi donc qui est de 14000 dollars le
dollar étant à 7 franc 50 ça fait une
belle enveloppe pour un 100000 francs
quoi ça fait 100000 francs c'est pas mal
ça fait 100000 francs tout à fait donc
un bravo à Elias mirine on se rappelle
que l'année dernière ça avait été trusté
par un trio arménien qui avait pris les
tris premir placeop je crois acopion
elpoution et anastasion ou mination ou
mination ouais enfin trois parmi quatre
en tout cas étaient aux trois premières
places donc Le Pen de New York attire
toujours les forts grands maîtres al on
peut noter donc qu' y avait la présence
de français notamment et de Christian
Bauer qui fait un très bon résultat
parce que sur la floppée de grand MRE
qui y avait plus de 200 joueurs titrés
je crois donc il réussi à une 13e place
remarquable il y avait 61 grand mtres il
est 13e en battant le russe Vladimir
epichine 2657 si je me trompe pas à la
dernière ronde donc très très belle
victoire de dernière ronde de Christian
Bauer qu'il met donc à la 13e place qui
est une bonne performance comp tenu des
61 grand m du tournoi c'est pas mal donc
Christian Bauer devient une valeur sûre
des échecs français je pense maintenant
que c'est il est entré dans le Top 5
français euh je vais vous donner mon
avis sur le joueur français au passage
c'est une parenthèse je pense qu'il y a
tier Étienne B en de premières plac
ensuite ils sont trois il y a Christian
Bauer Laurent Fressinet et peut-être
Igor Nataf qu'on ne voit pas assez
souvent en France mais qui joue très
bien et qui était également à New York
donc Igor finé qui est dans le top 5
junior mondial au dernier au classement
intermédiaire de la FIDÉ il est 5e
junior mondial donc c'est le il est
propulsé avec 2512 points ho donc il
grrimpe derrière derrière Dien Bro quand
même il me semble qu'il a 2517 oui oui
effectivement Laurent Fresin est très
très prometteur alors rappelons la
différence entre ces deux joueurs
Étienne bacRou a bénéficié de
d'entraîneur très jeune très tôt très
vite Laurent Fressin est autodidacte
puisque que jusqu'à 14 ans il n'a pas eu
d'entraîneur il a simplement lu des
livres et des revues donc leur en frine
est gros talent effectivement il est
moins fort qu'Étienne bac et il a un an
de plus mais sa marche de progression
est encore considérable puisque donc
tous les espoirs sont permis comme il
n'a jamais bénéficié de structure ni
d'aide particulière ouais il peut encore
avec peut-être un peu d'aide arriver à
grimper beaucoup plus haut oui oui tout
à fait donc Igor Nataf à New York
termine à la 46e place ça ne reflète pas
son tournoi puisqu'il était en tête tout
le tournoi enfin en tête il était dans
les bonnes places tout le tournoi Igor
natf qui j'espère on aura l'occasion de
le voir rapidement à diagonale dans une
émission future en tout cas tournoi de
New York ilasmine premier Christian
Bauer pas mal 13e Igor natf s'écroule
sur la fin 46e 46e alors on arrive après
on va parler du championnat de Hollande
qui se déroule actuellement non pas
parce que il est intéressant en soi mais
enfin surtout parce qu'il y a une
curiosité c'est que il y a un ordinateur
qui joue le championnat de Hollande
actuellement oui tout à fait alors que
bon en l'occurrence l'ordinateur est
Fritz qui n'est pas hollandais mais
plutôt allemand donc dans ce dans ce
cas-là on peut considérer que c'est une
aberration euh il y a une polémique qui
est lancée là-dessus puisque ça leur a
apporté beaucoup de publicité ils ont
fait la une du Daily téégraphhe par
exemple donc beaucoup de publicité mais
finalement un ordinateur dans un
championnat national ça ne ressemble à
rien tout simplement puisque ce qu'on
peut noter c'est que c'est pas forcément
l'ordinateur qui gagne effectivement
d'ailleurs l'ordinateur ne gagne pas il
a gagné une très très belle partie
contre je ne me rappelle plus de son nom
il a gagné une très belle partie
brillante avec les Noirs en 23 coups
contre V dendall contre Eric van dendall
le jaune le jeune hollandais mais par
contre s'est fait ramasser mais
proprement ramasser par Ly
vanvelli dans une mais alors une
miniature terrifiante où l'ordinateur
donc là vous avez vu la partie bakro
Kasparov et bien là c'était bien pire
c'était bien pire puisque l'ordinateur
n'a rien fait il a joué tour A8 A7 suite
tour A7 à8 n'a strictement consçu aucun
plan pendant que les blancs on
positionnellement avancé toute leur
armée vers le roi noir et ça donc a
appris 25 coups le le concepteur du
programme donc qui était manipulateur
commençait à s'arracher les cheveux en
voyant les coups générés par son propre
programme et effectivement donc
l'ordinateur a encore certaines lacunes
positionnelles à à combler donc en tout
cas ça ça prouve
que une conception humaine peut encore
peut encore aujourd'hui dépasser celle
de l'ordinateur oui là c'est le grand
débat le grand débat que tout le monde
connaît est-ce que si on arrive à
calculer une quantité gigantesque de
coup ça nous permettra de jouer des
coups disons si on Arve si on arrive à
tous si on arrive à tous les calculer
c'est sûr si on arrive à calculer
jusqu'au bout mais on sait que pour
calculer jusqu'au bout faudrait une
puissance de calcul qu'aujourd'hui on a
pas qu'on est probablement assez loin
d'avoir mais bon en tout cas Fritz ici
n'est clairement pas pas le plus fort
joueur du tournoi si on peut appeler ça
un joueur euh puisque je crois qu'il
pointe en milieu de tableau au milieu de
tableau supérieur probablement un petit
peu mais mais bon donc l' vanvelli est
en tête et ça me paraît tout à fait
logique cont tenu du fait que c'est
clairement l'espoir national hollandais
espoir en tout cas pour la couronne
mondiale puisque il a 2650 il a joué
beaucoup de tournois avec Kasparov c'est
le meilleur joueur c'est le joueur en
forme c'est le le jeune et talentueux
hollandais il y a picket qui qui est
très fort aussi ah oui j'avais oublié
j'avais oublié Irun pickat donc autant
pour moi Yun pickat également est très
fort il a battu Caspar récemment euh
donc il y a yantiman également donc là
Hollande non pas l'autre pays du fromage
mais l'autre pays des échecs puisque ils
ont généré beaucoup de talents voilà je
crois que on a fini avec les
informations je crois importantes de la
semaine alors la semaine prochaine on
fait évidemment diagonale spéciale
Sarajevo avec un invité de Marc un
invité de Marc un invité qui n'est pas
bosnique mais qui est français il s'agit
du président de la Fédération Française
deschac Jean-Claude Loubatière qui
viendra donc spécialement pour annoncer
le National le fameux championnat de
France le championnat de France qui aura
lieu à Vichy en cet été en fin d'août et
qui nous donnera évidemment un avis
éclairer sur la Fédération bosniaac sur
la FIDÉ et surt ce que ça implique donc
tout ce que connaît le président de la
fédération et sur le résultats du
tournoi le le parcours d'Étienne bac
aussi qui do suivre de près évidemment
bien entendu sur donc de toute façon ça
sera une émission encore spéciale
Sarajevo puisque c'est l'actualité du
moment l'événement sera toujours
sarillevo la partie sera de sarevo et
avec donc en tram de fond Jean-Claude
loubbatière donc notre président euh
fédéral qui joue très bien aux échecs
puisqu'il a un classement de 2200 points
lo ce qui estth ce qui est remarquable
ouais ce qui ce qui un très bon
classement c'est en tout cas plus fort
que le mien voilà donc ben on va arrêter
là cette émission je crois ça suffira
hein et on va se donner rendez-vous donc
la semaine prochaine pour spécial sarevo
en attendant évidemment tous les jours à
9h30 euh suivez alors soit 9h30 soit
après-midi euh donc les spécial flash
diagonal qu'on fait le matin à 9h30 donc
vous pouvez suivre donc soit en direct à
9h30 soit après-midi en différé où en
tous les jours donc nous commentant les
les parties de sarevo sauf le weekend
donc exceptionnellement pas de flash ce
weekend mais dès lundi vous aurez un
compte-rendu sur tout le weekend et
ensuite on enchaînera avec une semaine
complète de sarevo voilà à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine